Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Was ist los in den anderen europäischen Ligen als der Bundesliga? Dieser Frage gehen wir in Kurzpass nach und heute blicken wir mal mit Ben Barthman von Spock nach Spanien in La Liga. Ben, sei mir gegrüßt, schön, dass du mal wieder mit dabei bist.
Hi Max, ja ich freu mich auch mal wieder hier zu sein.
Ja, das letzte Mal haben wir gesprochen über die Situation bei Barca nach dem Weggang von Neymar. Man erkennt einen ganz leichten Themenschwerpunkt bei dir hier bei mir im Rasenfunk. Und was meinst du, werden wir heute auch über Barca sprechen, wenn wir über La Liga sprechen? Alles andere wäre fatal. In der Tat, ich habe es nochmal nachgeguckt. In den letzten fünf Jahren waren jeweils in der Endtabelle die Punkteabstände zwischen Platz 1 und Platz 2 wie folgt. Letzte Saison 3 Punkte Vorsprung für Real. In der Saison davor ein Pünktchen Vorsprung für Barca. In der Saison davor zwei Pünktchen Vorsprung. In der Saison davor drei Pünktchen Vorsprung für Atletico. Und das letzte, deutlichere Ergebnis hatten wir in der Saison 2012, 2013. Da hatte Barca fünf Punkte Vorsprung auf Tabellenplatz 2. Und jetzt gucke ich mir die aktuelle Tabelle an. Nach dem 28. Spieltag und Ben, ich reibe mir verwundert die Augen. Da sehe ich acht Punkte Vorsprung für Barca auf Atletico und sogar 15 Punkte auf Real Madrid. Was zur Hölle ist denn da los?
Ja, das ist ganz besonders spannend, weil ich glaube, wir haben im Neymar Podcast noch darüber gesprochen, ob denn Barca jetzt überhaupt noch oben dieses Spitzenduell halten kann ohne ihn. Und jetzt ist es genau andersrum gelaufen.
Wie konnten wir da so falsch liegen? Was war los, Ben? Ich hatte doch extra dich eingeladen.
Ja, wir hatten, glaube ich, gesagt, dass sie weiterhin oben mit dabei sind, aber das ist ein enges Rennenwirt. Das heißt, da lagen wir irgendwo falsch. Da hast du recht.
Und haben wir jetzt Barca unterschätzt oder Real überschätzt?
Ich denke, in diesem Fall haben wir tatsächlich Real überschätzt, wobei ich das auch gar nicht so stark sagen würde, weil am Ende, glaube ich, sind einfach ein paar unglückliche Bummstände zusammengekommen bei Real, die dann jetzt den richtig fetten Abstand ausmachen. Und Barca ist natürlich schon sehr, sehr gut unterwegs, bzw. sehr effektiv, sehr gebenlich viel aus der Hand, wenn man es so sagen will.
Das kann man bei einem Tabellenführer ohne Tabellenniederlage nach 28 Spielen kann man das, glaube ich, ganz gut behaupten.
Genau, das ist der entscheidende Punkt am Ende, dass Real eben tatsächlich in der Liga Spiele verloren hat, was man sonst eben nicht von ihnen erwartet. Gegen Espanyol beispielsweise ja kürzlich. Und Bassa eben auch mal diese 1-0-Dinger holt oder sich irgendwie ein bisschen durchwurstelt. Factor Messi natürlich auch. Und dann die Punkte nach Hause bringt, die Real zum Teil hat auch eben liegen lassen. Wobei das jetzt auch nur sehr, sehr grob gesagt ist natürlich.
Ja, durchwursteln und Factor Messi irgendwie scheinen diese beiden Worte gar nicht so wirklich zueinander zu passen. Was für ein Fußball spielt denn Barca in der Liga?
Einen sehr guten Fußball zurzeit drauf. Es ist nicht mehr dieses ganz klassische, wir erdrücken den Gegner bis zum Erbrechen. Das haben sie auch in den letzten Jahren ja nicht gemacht, ob es mal werde oder nicht. Aber sie sind auf jeden Fall sehr vielseitig. Sie haben ein gutes Ballbesitzspiel, sehr guten Spielaufbau wie immer natürlich. Dank Testigen unter anderem natürlich auch. Und kommen dann einfach auch sehr, sehr gut deswegen in diese offensiven Zonen rein, wo sie dann jetzt sowieso mit Coutinho, Dembélé, Messi, Suárez, Iniesta natürlich die ganzen guten Spieler dann auch wirklich versammelt haben. Gleichzeitig hat es bei Werder auch irgendwie geschafft, dass wieder ein bisschen mehr eine Mannschaft daraus geworden ist. Das heißt, schönes Pressing. Sie haben wirklich da zugelegt, finde ich. Sie gehen höher drauf, intensiver drauf, haben auch, finde ich, bessere Balleroberungen, zum Teil im oberen Mittelfeld sogar. Und dazu noch so eine physische Komponente, die nicht nur noch von Rakitic verkörpert wird, sondern auch eben Gut Suarez war auch in den letzten Jahren natürlich da. Aber jetzt auch mit Paulinho beispielsweise noch ein Faktor dazu gekommen, der in manchen Spielen wirklich wichtig sein kann.
Also so ein altes Barca-Spiel, wie wir es kennen, aber erweitert um eine physische Komponente gerade im Mittelfeld.
Ja, kann man so zusammenfassen, denke ich.
Wer sind so denn die entscheidenden Spieler? Außer jetzt natürlich Lionel Messi. Schon wieder 32 Tore, 16 Vorlagen. Unfassbar, dieser Mensch.
Ja, ich glaube, zu Messi ist tatsächlich – eigentlich kann man nie genug über ihn sagen, aber inzwischen weiß hat jeder Bescheid. Das heißt, wenn man ein bisschen auf den restlichen Kader guckt, man hat mit Testegen einen sehr, sehr, sehr guten, wenn nicht den besten Aufbau-Torwart im Kader. Das macht sehr, sehr viel aus, weil die Mannschaften in Spanien auch begriffen haben, dass sie gegen Barca mutig nach vorne gehen können, zum Teil, dass es wirklich auch Chancen birgt, wie nicht zuletzt Eibar beispielsweise größer gezeigt hat. Da ist Testegen in einer sehr, sehr wichtigen Rolle, weil er einfach ein Mann mehr ist. Dann spielt man wirklich 11 gegen 10, auch wenn die Gegner eben versuchen, da wirklich eins gegen eins auf dem Feld zu verteidigen. Gleichzeitig hat Alba auf der linken Seite eine herauslagend starke Saison bis jetzt. Gerade im Zusammenspiel mit Messi, der weiß ganz genau, was er da zu tun hat. Er wird von Umtiti auf der linken Seite aufgefangen in seinen offensiven Bewegungen. So ein bisschen Umtiti auch in dieser Saison, in die Weltklasse vorgestoßen, meiner Meinung nach. Der ist so sicher und so abgeklärt, dass ich mich manchmal frage, ob er nicht inzwischen eigentlich der wichtigere Teil ist im Vergleich mit Piquet auf der rechten Innenseite. Ja, rechts ist es ein bisschen Roberto Semedo. Das ist nicht ganz ideal, glaube ich, nicht ganz so, wie wir es geplant haben. Aber Roberto hat seine Rolle da eigentlich übernommen, macht das ganz gut. Dann haben wir im Mittelfeld natürlich das übliche Boosketts Iniesta, einfach immer noch absolute Topspitze. Und vorne ist Juarez Messi, brauchen wir auch nicht darüber reden. Jetzt eben mit den neuen Komponenten Dembélé und Coutinho ist da noch ein bisschen mehr Kreativität, ein bisschen mehr Zug nach vorne sicherlich auch dazugekommen. Aber das bietet sich momentan alles noch so ein bisschen ein. Also das, denke ich, muss auch noch bis zur vollen Entfaltung. Dauert das noch ein bisschen.
Ja, gerade Dembélé hat sich ja früh verletzt und so arg viele Partien jetzt noch nicht gemacht. Also 11 sind hier notiert, aber davon viele gar nicht über die volle Spielzeit. Wie machen sich denn Dembélé und Coutinho bisher bei Barca?
Ich finde, wenn wir mal mit Coutinho anfangen, vielleicht, der sich ein bisschen schneller und besser integriert hat gleich, was ihm sicherlich auch einfach gefallen ist, weil Suárez und Messi ihn gleich direkt unter ihre Fittiche genommen haben, die sich ja auch privat sehr gut mit ihm verstehen. Die haben ihn da sehr schnell in die Mannschaft eingebaut. Er findet sich natürlich gut zurecht mit seinen Fähigkeiten in diesem Spiel, kann verschiedene Positionen begleiten. Das ist natürlich noch ein Faktor, der ihn wirklich eigentlich sehr schnell in diese Mannschaft eingebracht hat. Das heißt, es läuft noch nicht alles perfekt, aber ich denke, schon im ersten Spiel konnte man so ein bisschen sehen, was dieses Duo Messi-Coutinho plus X dann noch wirklich anrichten kann. Und auf der anderen Seite Dembele, denke ich, hat jetzt im letzten Spiel sehr gut gezeigt – er gegen Malaga – was er kann und was er theoretisch kann, leider nur. Denn bis jetzt fehlt so ein bisschen, es gibt jetzt auch viele Gerüchte, Privatleben, ob er jetzt zu viel Fastfood isst oder nicht, schwer zu sagen, anscheinend durchlaufen seine Eltern gerade eine Scheidung. Und er steckt da ein bisschen drin, glaube ich, als junger Kerl nach Barcelona gezogen, keine Freunde mitgebracht. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig, aber der Klub hat das erkannt, er scheint daran zu arbeiten und dementsprechend, denke ich, wird er sich auch einfinden, weil man ja gerade, was junge Spiele angeht, wie Dembele, auf was so ein Beinegeld gekostet hat, wird man sicherlich geduldig sein und abwarten, was da daraus wird und ihm sicherlich auch sämtliche Zeit und Maßnahmen dann geben, die man irgendwie ergreifen kann, um sein Potenzial zu entfalten.
Ja, wenn ich mir jetzt die Bilanz von Barcelona nach diesen 28 Spielen anschaue, dann sehe ich 72 erzielte Tore, 13 kassierte Tore, das ist unglaublich wenig. Wenn wir jetzt mal dagegen die Bilanz von Real Madrid stellen, dann haben wir 67 erzielte Tore, das ist recht nahe an den 72, aber 30 kassierte, das heißt mehr als das Doppelte, als das, was Barca kassiert hat. Ist das auch der wesentliche Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden Mannschaften?
Ja, Barcelona hat auf jeden Fall eine sehr gute defensive Stabilität in diesem Jahr. Wie gesagt, Testegen, Alba, Umtiti, da ist einfach sehr viel Qualität in sehr guter Form momentan vorhanden. Und ich glaube, die Form ist bei Real so ein bisschen die Sache, denn die haben in wichtigen Momenten echt Nackenschläge kassiert und sind ein bisschen runtergefallen von der guten Form, mit der sie in die Saison gegangen sind eigentlich. Dazu kommt, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen – es ist halt eine etwas wildere Abwehr, wenn man so will. Marcelo, dann hat man Cavajal rechts, das sind sehr offensive Außenverteidiger. Ramos, der ja auch ein bisschen vorwärts verteidigt, sage ich mal, plus X. Und das ist vielleicht auch ein Problem, man weiß nicht so recht, wer ist jetzt eigentlich der Zweite. Es ist Varane, man hat jetzt nicht alles gespielt. Dann hat man Vallejo natürlich, der von Frankfurt zurückgekommen ist, der schon auf Realniveau ist. Das ist halt auch ein bisschen zu diskutieren. Ich glaube aber letztendlich liegt es vor allem daran, dass man eben wirklich Verteidiger hat, die sehr gerne vorwärts verteidigen, die aktiv verteidigen wollen. Und die muss man dann in so ein Gesamtkonzept schon irgendwie einbauen und die auch dadurch unterstützen, dass vorhin ein Gegenpressing stattfindet, dass man gut umschaltet und dass man die Abwehr halt nicht alleine lässt. Und ich glaube, daran gab es auch durchaus Probleme in diesem Jahr.
Ist denn Keylan Navas, also der Torhüter, auch eins dieser Probleme? Das ist mir aufgefallen beim Blick auf die Statistiken, dass Real Madrid pro Spiel 10 Schüsse aus eigener Tour lässt, Tor zulässt Barça 10, 3 Schüsse. Also da sind sie gar nicht so weit auseinander, aber die einen haben mal 13 Tore gesät, die anderen 30.
Ob Navas das das große Problem ist, weiß ich nicht unbedingt. Ich denke eigentlich, auf der Linie ist er ein ordentlicher Torwart. Er ist sicher nicht dieses Spitzen-Niveau, das man sich bei Real auf jeder einzelnen Position wünscht, aber ich denke, er ist auf einem guten Niveau. Er ist halt im Aufbau ein bisschen schwächer, ein bisschen sehr viel schwächer als Testigen vielleicht sogar. Ich glaube, man muss da ein bisschen unterscheiden in der Schussqualität. Wir haben ja gerade darüber gesprochen, dass die Abwehr auch irgendwie unterstützt werden muss durch einen gegenfessigen. Wenn das nicht so gut funktioniert, wie es jetzt zum Beispiel bei Barcelona tut, dann kommt der Gegner natürlich in aussichtsreichere Chancen, hat bessere Abschlüsse und daraus entstehen auch mehr Tore. Es sind mehr Tore daraus zu erwarten. Ich denke, das ist tatsächlich der große Unterschied. Ob Navas da jetzt der riesige Faktor ist, vielleicht ein kleiner genauso wie auch andere Faktoren, aber ich denke, ich würde ihn nicht als entscheidend bezeichnen, was das angeht.
Real auch im Vergleich zu Barca acht Tore nach Standard-Situationen kassiert. Barca mit nur einem, da Liga weit spitze. Das ist sicherlich noch ein zweiter Aspekt, der mit dazu kommt. Jetzt wissen wir ja alle, dass die Ansprüche von Real Madrid natürlich nur die höchsten sind. Auf der anderen Seite würde jetzt aber auch, ich denke, jeder Hörer und jede Hörerin mitgehen, wenn ich sage, man kann aber auch nicht immer alles gewinnen. Wie ist denn die Lage rund um Trainer Sinedine Zidane und das Umfeld in Madrid?
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu beurteilen, weil Zidane halt einen unglaublichen Kredit wirklich mitbringt durch seine beiden Champions League Siege, durch seine Rolle einfach, dass er eben Zidane ist, seine Spielervergangenheit da hat, dass er sich ja offensichtlich sehr gut mit den Spielern versteht. Also er hat ein wirklich großes Konto gehabt, schon vor der Saison, an dem wird jetzt hier und da natürlich mal durch die Ergebnisse ein bisschen Minus gemacht worden. Ich glaube aber, dass er momentan die wirklich kritische Phase überstanden hat, natürlich auch durch das Erreichen des Viertelfinals jetzt. In der Liga-Situation sicherlich unglücklich, das wird real auch auffallen, aber ich denke, dass er momentan wieder relativ solide unterwegs ist und dass man sicherlich mit ihm auch diese Saison beenden wird. Dann vielleicht gibt es da Überlegungen, weil es kann ja durchaus sein, dass man vielleicht neue Wege gehen will, aber es ist noch sehr weit in der Zukunft. Ich glaube, er hat vor kurzem mal selber gesagt, er hätte den Vertrag verlängert und meinte gleich einen Tag später oder ich glaube noch während der Pressekonferenz zur Verlängerung, der Vertrag ist mehr oder weniger Schall und Rauch, weil am Ende entscheidet der Präsident, ob er jetzt wirklich den Vertrag erfüllt oder nicht. Ich denke aber, momentan ist er relativ sicher und solange er jetzt nicht völlig dramatisch abstürzt, auf einmal sollte diese Saison auch mit ihm zu Ende gehen. Wie es dann weitergeht, ist ein bisschen unsicher. Aber ich denke im Normalfall sollten sie auch weitermachen.
Und jetzt hast du vorhin schon so ein bisschen angedeutet, das Problem von Real ist vor allem, dass man Punkte liegen lässt, schon fünfmal verloren, sechsmal unentschieden gespielt. Daher kommt dieser wesentliche Abstand, also die fünf Niederlagen machen exakt die 15 Punkte zur Barse aus. Jetzt neben dem Klassik, den vielleicht noch der ein oder andere und die ein oder andere mitbekommen hat, kann man festmachen, woran das liegt oder steckt da kein System dahinter, hinter diesen Niederlagen?
Tja, wenn man das jetzt einfach sagen könnte, dann wären wir Trainer bei Real und nicht die dann. Aber ich glaube, es kommen ein paar verschiedene Sachen zusammen. Man hat ja, wie gesagt, wir haben schon ein bisschen über die Abwehr gesprochen. Ich denke, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Faktor, dass die Mannschaft nicht mehr so taktisch geschlossen agiert. Wir haben auch in den letzten Jahren schon eine Realmannschaft gesehen, meiner Meinung nach, die sehr gut zusammengestellt war in ihren Spielertypen und in ihren verschiedenen Rollen. Die sehr gut ausgefüllt war und von sie dann einfach so ein bisschen moderiert, weil das so ein bisschen klingt, als wäre der Shout, dass alle bei Laune bleiben. Aber er hat ein sehr gutes Grundgerüst und das muss er dann mit wenigen taktischen Mitteln anpassen. Er muss keine großen Meisterleistungen vollbringen, wie es jetzt vielleicht kleinere Mannschaften machen müssen. So ein Real konnte größtenteils sein Spiel spielen, konnte seine Qualitäten ausspielen. Und ich denke, das war sicherlich auch ein großer Faktor für den Erfolg. Er hatte zum Beispiel immer sehr, sehr viele Leute im Spielaufbau. Also er hat einen sehr, sehr, sehr stabilen Spielaufbau mit auch enorm vielen Leuten. Dafür relativ wenig Spieler nach vorne. Das hatte man ein bisschen komisch angemutet, sag ich mal, weil Real eigentlich mutig nach vorne spielen sollte. Aber er hat dann doch sehr, sehr auf Sicherheit gebaut. Das ist auch jetzt immer noch so. Ich glaube, Real hat eine sehr, sehr große Pass-Sicherheit oder Passquote. Das ist sehr, sehr gut. Ich glaube, sogar die beste Liga müsste es sein, noch vor Barcelona. Gleichzeitig kriegt man aber nach vorne nicht diesen letzten Punch rein, was dann vielleicht auch zurückzuführen ist auf Ronaldo, der eine bisschen andere Rolle trägt, der aus einer anderen Position zum Abschluss kommt, der nicht mehr ganz so effektiv war am Anfang der Saison in der Liga. Dazu hast du Bale, der wirklich durchhängt. Du hast Benzema, der durchhängt. Isco, der irgendwie sehr wechselhaft spielt. Phasenweise ist der ja wirklich eine Augenweide, wenn man da zuguckt. Auf der anderen Seite hat er wirklich Spiele, wo er mal für 30 Minuten, für 40 Minuten wirklich abtaucht. Also bisher hat sie dann sehr viel gelebt von dieser offensiven Qualität, die sie einfach hatte. Er hat geguckt, dass er sie sicher einsetzen kann, dass sie ihre Qualitäten ausspielen können. Jetzt sind sie in ein Formloch gefallen. Und das sogar zum gleichen Zeitpunkt mehrere Spieler. Und das macht natürlich auch bei Real dann was aus. Gerade wenn man bedenkt, dass dann die Alternativen eben so Leute sind, wie Lucas Vazquez oder Marco Asensio, die sicher Potenzial haben, die ihre Rollen sehr gut spielen können, aber die noch keine Mannschaft zum Sieg führen, sage ich mal.
Und man muss einschränken, wenn du sagst, Ronaldo ein bisschen weniger effizient und torgefährlich in neuer Rolle, dann sprechen wir immer noch von 18 Ligatoren in 22 Spielen. Also es ist alles trotzdem noch in einem Niveau, auf dem man sich sonst selten aufhält. Zwischen Barca und Real steht Atletico Madrid mit 64 Punkten. Das heißt, es sind 8 Punkte Rückstand auf Barca gerade und 7 Punkte Vorsprung auf Real. Und bei Atletico, da weiß ich gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll. Die haben ja nur noch 19 Spieler im Kader. Was zur Hölle ist bei Atletico los?
Also ich denke, Atletico ist momentan sicherlich sehr zu üben mit dem zweiten Platz. Nicht nur durch den Vorsprung auf Real, sondern auch einfach dadurch, dass sie eben sicherlich kein Verein sind, der sagt, wir möchten hier Erster werden oder wir möchten auch unbedingt Zweiter werden. Ich denke, ihnen geht es einfach darum, dass sie die Champions League jedes Jahr immer wieder erreichen und vielleicht in einem guten Jahr irgendwo mal ein bisschen wen ärgern können. Das heißt, ich würde den zweiten Platz nicht als Krise oder Ähnliches bezeichnen.
Nee, das gar nicht. Der Erfolg ist super, aber gleichzeitig schrumpft denen der Kader weg. Denn ständig gehen Spieler verloren. Jetzt ja gerade gerne nach China.
Das ist richtig, ja. Ich denke, Simeon ist so ein Trainer, der wirklich die Spieler zu 100 Prozent voll dabei haben. Und wenn er eben merkt, der eine Spieler ist jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr zu 100 Prozent dabei, dem hat das Geld aus China vielleicht ein bisschen den Kopf verdreht, dann ist er, glaube ich, ein Trainer, der sagt, okay, dann gehe. Passt schon. Solange die Mannschaft intakt bleibt, solange dieser Mannschaftsgeist, der wirklich bei Atletico enorm stark ausgeprägt ist, solange der ein bisschen bestehen bleibt. Ich denke, er ist da wirklich so ein Trainer. Es gibt immer ein bisschen Gerüchte, wie er seine Spieler aussucht. Da scheint es schon sehr, sehr viel Augenmerk darauf zu legen, dass dieser Spieler kommt und 100 Prozent hinter dem Trainer und hinter dem Verein oder hinter dem Projekt steht. Deswegen, glaube ich, hat man das so ein bisschen einfach wahrgenommen. Dann geht es halt. Wir kriegen das auch ohne euch hin. Wir finden schon wieder andere Spieler. Nur die Auswahl ist im Winter sowieso schon eingeschränkt. Dazu kommt dann, denke ich, dass Simeone ein sehr anspruchsvolles Profil hat. Daraus entsteht vielleicht auch mal ein kleinerer Kader. Ich denke aber, dass Atletico das schon relativ gut auffangen kann, sei es durch Spieler, die vielleicht mal aus der zweiten Reihe nachrutschen oder auch einfach durch einen sehr guten Mannschaftszusammenhalt. Dadurch, dass auch einige Spieler sehr flexibel einsetzbar sind.
Ja, in der Liga nur zwei Niederlagen, nämlich gegen beide Vereine aus Barcelona. Einmal Espanol und einmal Barça themselves. Wenn man das Buch Football Leagues konsumiert von Raphael Buschmann und Michael Wulzinger, dann lernt man sehr viel über Atletico und über die Verstrickungen, die da vom Präsidenten und zu bestimmten Spieleragenturen bestehen. Ist das denn, also diese ganzen Enthüllungen von Football Leagues, auch in Spanien ein Thema?
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema. Die Medien stürzen sich natürlich unglaublich gerne darauf. Das wird sehr gern präsentiert, sehr gern hergezeigt. Letztendlich habe ich aber ein bisschen so das Gefühl, das ist vielleicht auch in Deutschland vergleichbar. Es kommt immer darauf an, wo man guckt, dass viele Leute aber sagen, ja mei, so ist es halt. Und das einfach so ein bisschen, ja, habe ich jetzt schon gelesen, aber letztendlich, was interessiert mich das, solange der Junge seine Tore schießt, so ungefähr. Das gefühlt habe ich auch ein bisschen in Spanien, dass da die Leute das natürlich schon lesen und wahrnehmen, aber letztendlich ist es kein Grund, um zu sagen, ok, jetzt entferne ich mich vom Fußball, jetzt gehe ich nicht mehr ins Stadion, jetzt möchte ich Atletico nicht mehr sehen. Das ist, glaube ich, dafür nicht Faktor genug.
Also keine Fußballmüdigkeit in Spanien. Dann haben wir auf Tabellenplatz 4 Valencia sitzen und dahinter dann Sevilla und Villarreal mit einigen Abstand dann schon. Kann man davon sprechen, dass die ersten 4, also Barca, Atletico, Real und Valencia die Liga dominieren?
Wenn man sich rein die Punkte anschaut, müsste man das so sagen, ja. Ich denke, von Barca, Atletico und Real, die haben sich ohnehin schon so einen großen Vorsprung wirklich erarbeitet. Dass man das von den dreien auf jeden Fall sagen kann. Ich glaube, Valencia ist in dieser Saison natürlich sehr stark. Das sieht man ja an der Tabelle. Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, dass die sich noch nicht wirklich entfernt haben im Sinne von dominieren gegenüber Sevilla, Villarreal oder meinetwegen auch Bilbao oder Real Sociedad. Die sind alle so ein bisschen, klar, Stückweise auseinander, aber das ist trotzdem noch so die zweite Riege im spanischen Fußball. Das heißt, die ersten drei Jahre Valencia würde ich da noch rausnehmen. Die spielen aber auch momentan eine sehr gute Saison.
Haben den jüngsten Kader der ganzen Liga mit knapp 25 Jahren Durchschnittsalter. Merkt man das auch am Fußball, den Valencia spielt?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das unbedingt am Alter festmachen kann. Ich würde es tatsächlich zu einem sehr, sehr großen Teil am Trainer festmachen. Ich halte unglaublich viel von Marcelinho. Der hat auch bei Villarreal schon sehr, sehr gute Arbeit geleistet. Ist dann da unter ein bisschen konfusen Umständen damals gegangen. Jetzt hat er bei Valencia eine wirklich von den Anlagen her wunderbare Mannschaft, finde ich, die ganz viele verschiedene und super interessante Spielerrollen hat. Sehr, sehr jung, mit wirklich vielen interessanten Spielern, mit großem Potential. Gleichzeitig ein bisschen kombiniert natürlich mit ein paar Jungs, die die spanische Liga oder auch die ein bisschen mehr schon sehen und gesehen haben. Also Parejo zum Beispiel ist da ja ein Beispiel. Condog B ist, denke ich, ein ganz wichtiger Mann im Mittelfeld, die ja mit 25 oder 28 dann auch schon ein bisschen drüber raus sind. Oder Rodrigo beispielsweise ist ja auch schon 27, meine ich. Das ist, glaube ich, einfach eine gute Kombination, die mit einem sehr, sehr guten Trainer wirklich was entfaltet, was, glaube ich, bisher noch nicht so gut gelungen ist, dass man aus dem Kader in dieser Konstellation so viel rausholt. Das macht der ganze Verein wirklich hervorragend. Und sie sind sehr spielfreudig, ja, da hast du recht. Es ist wirklich schön, Valencia Spiele anzugucken. Marcelinho ist so ein Trainer, der sehr viel Wert darauf legt, dass seine Jungs sich nicht nur als Mannschaft weiterentwickeln, sondern auch einzeln, dass sie ein bisschen dazulernen, dass sie ein sauberes Passspiel haben beispielsweise. Da liegt er sehr, sehr Wert darauf. Er trainiert sehr viel mit Rondos, mit Positionsspielen. Das ist ein sehr, sehr interessantes Training. Da kann man sich immer ein bisschen was abgucken, wenn man da selber daran interessiert ist. Und das kommt sicherlich gut an, weil die Spielertypen auch einfach zu diesem Fußball passen.
Drittbester Angriff der kompletten Liga. Und das erklärt dann auch, wie man dann auf Tabellenplatz 4 landet. Was sind denn so Teams, wo du sagst, die hat man vielleicht jetzt auch so gar nicht auf den Schirm gehabt? Gibt es große Überraschungen in La Liga?
Die gibt es auf jeden Fall. Also wir müssen auf jeden Fall sprechen über Girona, die momentan auf dem Sittenplatz steht. Als Aufsteiger? Genau, als Aufsteiger und vor allem als absoluter Debutant. Das gab, als die ersten in Barcelona gespielt haben, sensationelle Bilder, wie sie in diesem riesigen Stadion stehen und total beeindruckt von der Atmosphäre auf diesem Rasen herumwandern und mehr oder weniger vergessen haben, dass sie eigentlich auch irgendwann wieder reingehen sollten. Das war wirklich ein sehr schöner Moment, finde ich, weil er sehr gut gezeigt hat, wo die eigentlich herkommen. Dann haben wir neben Cirona noch Eiber, die auch eine sehr, sehr gute Saison spielen. Ich glaube, momentan einen Platz dahinter, also auf Rang 8. Und wenn wir wollen, können wir noch Retafe reinnehmen, die auf dem elsten Platz stehen. Auch als Aufsteiger, genau. Und ich glaube, dass auch alle drei Mannschaften die Mannschaft mit dem niedrigsten oder unter dem niedrigsten Etat sein müssten, die trotzdem aus ihren Möglichkeiten sehr viel machen. Und die kann man durchaus als Überraschung bezeichnen, würde ich behaupten. Vor allem Cirona, die jetzt natürlich eventuell sogar international Fußball spielen könnten im nächsten Jahr.
Ja, das ist schon ziemlich irre. Kann man festmachen, woran es liegt, dass Cirona als Aufsteiger so gut spielt? Wurden die einfach getragen von einer Welle des Erfolgs? Und dann ist es halt so, wie es manchmal ist, dass einem dann der nächste Sieg dann auch so ein bisschen in den Schoß fällt? Oder haben die ein überlegendes Spielsystem, einen ganz tollen Trainer, ein brasilianisches Wundertalent? Woran liegt es, Ben?
Puh, also Cirona hat sehr, sehr, sehr viele Leihspiele. Das ist schon mal das Erste, was man, glaube ich, ansprechen muss. Das heißt, der Erfolg ist ein bisschen auf Zeit geholt. Also ich glaube, sie haben von Manchester City – ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher – vier oder fünf Spiele ausgeliehen. Dazu kommen Moniesa beispielsweise auch aus England, von Stoke City. Also da wurde Qualität auf Zeit erstmal in den Kader geschafft. Sicherlich auch mit dem Hintergedanken-Klassen-Erhalt, dass man den erstmal sichert, sich finanziell ein bisschen einarbeitet in die Liga und dann vielleicht im nächsten Jahr ein paar Möglichkeiten hat. Vielleicht kann man den einen oder anderen Spieler ja gewinnen, vielleicht kann man ihn halten. Das sicherlich auch auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite ist es eine sehr disziplinierte Mannschaft. Die habe ich immer das Gefühl, die wissen sehr genau, das ist meine Aufgabe auf dem Platz, das muss ich tun. Die wirken wirklich eingespielt. Und was man auch auf jeden Fall erwähnen muss, ist die Standardstärke, die sie haben. Ich glaube, im letzten Spiel müssten zwei von zwei Toren nach Freistößen gefallen sein. Das heißt, sie spielen da auch wirklich die Stärke des Underdogs ein bisschen aus. Ich glaube, das sind die beiden entscheidenden Faktoren tatsächlich, dass auf der einen Seite eine sehr eingespielte Mannschaft ist und auf der anderen Seite auch durch Laien ein bisschen Löcher gestopft wurden hier und da, die existiert haben und die eine gute Qualität mit reinbringen in die Mannschaft.
Und Eibar, über die bin ich vorhin schon die ganze Zeit gestolpert. Als ich zum Beispiel geguckt habe, wer hat denn so statistisch gesehen eine gute Verteidigung, dann liegt Eibar ganz, ganz weit vorne mit den niedrigsten Schüssen des Gegners aufs eigene Tor. 8, 2 noch vor Madrid, vor Retafel, vor Barca, vor Real Sociedad, die alle 10 oder mehr Schüsse pro Spiel zulassen. Und auch in der Offensive ist Eibar ganz gut, liegt da auf Platz 4 in den Schüssen aufs gegnerische Tor. Das heißt, vorne wie hinten scheint es da zu stimmen und man schlägt da auch durchaus, zumindest in der Statistik, so manchen der großen Namen. Was steckt dahinter? Wundersystem?
Wundersystem jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt. Ich glaube, auch da muss man wieder einfach über einen guten Plan für die richtigen Spieler sprechen. Das ist allgemein eine Sache in Spanien, die man wirklich betonen kann, dass da sehr, sehr gute Arbeit von den Trainern geleistet wird. Die haben wirklich gute Leute am Start. Jetzt auch bei Eibar mit Mendy Libar. Nicht der größte Name, den wird man jetzt in Deutschland nicht sofort erkennen. Aber die wissen einfach in vielen Fällen, was sie mit der Qualität, die sie da haben, anfangen können. Und ich glaube, gerade bei Eibar ist das jetzt natürlich, genau wie du sagst, perfekt aufgegangen eigentlich. Ich denke, da in den Statistiken so weit oben vertreten zu sein, das sagt schon sehr, sehr viel aus über die Mannschaftsqualität. Nicht nur einzeln, sondern auch in dem Fall vor allem kollektiv. Das ist wirklich eine Mannschaft. Wenn ich da als elf Namen vorlese, dann sagt man in Deutschland vielleicht, man hat einen oder zwei, vielleicht schon gehört, Takashi Inui zum Beispiel, kennt man ja aus der Bundesliga, oder Pedro León vielleicht auch noch der eine oder andere. Aber ansonsten ist es wirklich eine Mannschaft, die einem jetzt nicht direkt ins Auge springt. Aber dadurch, dass sie sehr, sehr gut das Kollektiv abliefern, sind sie momentan so weit oben. Und das ist meiner Meinung nach auch sehr viel wieder zurückzuführen auf den Trainer, der eine sehr gute Arbeit macht. Und übrigens nur noch bis zum Ende, der Saisonvertrag hat. Da wird es auf jeden Fall interessant, ob er denn jetzt noch bleibt oder ob er dann nicht vielleicht sogar sich woanders umguckt. Und auch in dem Fall, auch wieder Thema sicherlich, verschiedene Lien von Spielern. Denn auch da ist wieder viel auf Zeit gemacht worden. Also Orellana zum Beispiel, ist von Valencia ausgeliehen. Vielleicht auch so ein Grund, warum man dann sagt, dass Trainer ja mit Vertragsende vielleicht schaue ich mich nochmal woanders um. Denn hier verdiene ich wirklich jedes Jahr dann eben leider meine besten Spiele.
Ist das jetzt Zufall, dass wir viel über Mannschaften sprechen, die sich den aktuellen Erfolg geliehen haben? Oder ist das ein Trend in der spanischen Liga, dass man viele Leihgeschäfte macht? Hat es auch mit der finanziellen Dominanz von England zu tun? Wie kommt das?
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema in Spanien. Also wir sind noch nicht an diesen italienischen Niveaus angekommen. Dass hier 30-40 Leihspieler irgendwo durch die Gegend wandern. Aber wie schon gesagt, die Spanier machen wirklich eine gute Arbeit derzeit neben dem Platz. Und da, finde ich, gehört es auch dazu, dass man eben ein sehr gutes Scouting-System hat, wenn man schon nicht die großen Transfersummen schlecht bezahlen kann, weil Real und Barca ja wirklich sehr dominant auftreten, was diese TV-Summen angeht, die da kassiert werden. Die da in England wirklich auf einem ganz anderen Level eigentlich sind. Wenn sie auch in Spanien natürlich gestiegen sind, sind die Spanier noch nicht auf diesem Niveau. Und gerade die Aufsteiger oder so Mannschaften wie Eiber, über die wir jetzt sprechen, müssen schon sich ein bisschen schlau auf den Markt behaupten. Und da ist eine Laie natürlich immer eine gute Möglichkeit, weil sie auch einfach interessante Angebote natürlich geben können. Es wird oft attraktiver Fußball gespielt, man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, hier werden Spieler entwickelt in Spanien, die machen Fortschritte, die können auch wirklich sich präsentieren irgendwie in großen Duellen, Real, Barca, Atletico. Also ich denke, da hat man viele Argumente auf seiner Seite und deswegen sind diese Laien auch wirklich beliebt, wobei das jetzt noch nicht so ausgeartet ist wie vielleicht in Italien.
Und jetzt hast du vorher noch den FC Retafel angesprochen, der auch als Aufsteiger aktuell auf Platz 11 liegt mit 36 Punkten. Das sind 16 Punkte Vorsprung auf die Abstiegszone. Und wenn ich mir da den Kader angucke auf transfermarkt.de, dann sehe ich eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Leute, die nicht aktuell in diesem Sommer gekommen sind, als feste Verpflichtung oder wiederum als Laie. Das heißt, die haben nach dem Aufstieg erstmal schön komplett im Grunde die Mannschaft ausgetauscht.
Ja, das hat man anscheinend als wichtig angesehen. Da sind ja wirklich ganz verschiedene Typen gekommen. Also von Flammini zum Beispiel könnte man ja anfangen. Über Antunes aus der Ukraine ist der ausgeliehen worden, von Kiew bis hin zu Leuten wie Pacheco beispielsweise, der ja in Spanien lange mal als eigentlich ein großes Talent galt und jetzt irgendwie sein Glück bei Retafel sucht. Also da ist Qualität geholt worden, die sich momentan auch wieder ein bisschen auszahlt. Wobei ich immer bei Retafel so das Gefühl habe, die performen ein bisschen besser als es vielleicht am Ende wirklich sein sollte. Wobei der Abstand natürlich schon für sich spricht, da hast du recht.
Wenn wir jetzt mal so allgemein auf die spanische Liga gucken, du weißt ja denke ich auch, was man so über die Bundesliga sagt aktuell und deren Spielniveau. Wie ist denn so ein durchschnittliches spanisches Spiel? Jetzt auch mal weg von den großen Namen, von Barca, Atletico Real.
Das kann sehr, sehr unterschiedlich sein. Also es gibt wirklich Spiele, die machen unglaublich viel Spaß. Es kommt ja ein bisschen darauf an. Natürlich ist es in der Bundesliga auch so, wer gegen wen spielt. Das ist ja eh klar. Grundsätzlich hat sich aber auch so ein bisschen dieses Gefühl etabliert. Momentan können viele Mannschaften viele andere Mannschaften schlagen. Da sind dann Barca und Atletico in dieser Saison nochmal eine Ausnahme. Real kann man ja anscheinend auch schlagen. Das hat sich in dieser Saison gezeigt. Es ist mehr eine Momentaufnahme natürlich. Die drei muss man immer ein bisschen rausnehmen. Aber ansonsten sieht man da auch relativ schon eine Annäherung. Nicht so stark wie in der Bundesliga, mit diesem wirklich, hier kann jeder gegen jeden gewinnen, die Bayern mal außen vor gelassen. Aber sie kommen sich näher. Und das macht auch viel Attraktivität aus, finde ich eigentlich. Auch in der Bundesliga, es ist halt einfach so eine spannende Spielansetzung. Man hat zwar nicht mehr dieses klassische Favorit und Underdog, aber man hat Mannschaften, die mehr mit ihren Mitteln versuchen zu gewinnen. Das ist sicherlich auch interessant. Ist dann aber natürlich auch wieder abhängig von der Mannschaft. Also es gibt wirklich Mannschaften, die kann man sich sehr gut angucken, wie wir vorhin gesagt haben. Valencia beispielsweise, Betis beispielsweise, oder auch Las Palmas, die leider auf dem Abstiegsplatz stehen. Von denen bin ich normalerweise wirklich angetan. Und gleichzeitig hat man auch einfach Mannschaften wie Eiber beispielsweise. Die wissen halt, wie sie verteidigen, wie sie dicht halten. Da macht es dann vielleicht nicht ganz so viel Spaß. Oder Leganes zum Beispiel ist auch so eine Mannschaft, die weiß einfach, wie verteidigt wird, macht extrem wenig Tore. Das ist dann nicht der Kracher des Spieltags unbedingt, wenn die irgendwo mit involviert sind.
In der Bundesliga habe ich sechs Mannschaften, die mehr den Ball haben als der Gegner. Durchschnittlich gesehen über alle Partien. In Spanien sind es davon neun. Jetzt hat Spanien allerdings noch zwei Teams mehr als die Bundesliga. Kann man da Rückschlüsse daraus ziehen? Das Klischee ist, dass spanische Mannschaften besser mit dem Ball umgehen können und die deshalb auch lieber haben mögen als deutsche.
Ich glaube, in Spanien liegt tatsächlich ein sehr großer Fokus, wie wir auch gerade bei Marcelinho schon angesprochen haben, auf diesen klassischen Ballbesitz-Halten spielen. Es ist oft eine andere Trainingsphilosophie. Wir üben einen Ablauf, wir üben beispielsweise einen Spielzug. Wir spielen durch, hin zu den Spaniern, die eher in die Richtung gehen. Wir versuchen, dass jeder Spieler auf seiner Position weiß, welche Entscheidungen er hat, welche er treffen kann und die nötigen Mittel dafür hat. Es ist ein bisschen freier, wobei das natürlich auch wieder einfach so dahingesagt ist und jetzt nicht für jeden Trainer zutrifft. Das heißt, es ist ein Unterschied in der Trainingsarbeit, in der Jugendarbeit, in der Philosophie sicherlich auch. Diese spanisch-niederländische Schule zum Teil ist auf jeden Fall vorhanden mit dem Ballwollen und mit Ballspielen. Gleichzeitig ist die Spanische Liga natürlich auch so internationale. Da kommen Einflüsse von außen rein. Das heißt, ich würde das nicht so pauschalisieren. Ich glaube aber, dass die Tendenz eher dazu geht, dass man versucht, auch in Ballbesitz etwas anrichten zu können. Vielleicht zur Bundesliga, wo man ja gerne sagt, das ist die neue Pressing-Liga, dass man einen Unterschied darstellt.
Interessant finde ich. Man soll ja auch Statistik nicht überbewerten, aber deswegen werfe ich die Statistik ja auch jetzt einem Experten hin, der sie dann einordnen kann und mir dann auch gerne sagen kann, ne, das ist Quatsch. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir die Dribblings pro Spiel anschaue, dann habe ich in La Liga 11 Mannschaften, die 10 oder mehr Dribblings pro Spiel machen, und in der Deutschen Bundesliga ist es genau eine Mannschaft, nämlich Leipzig.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Faktor. Ich glaube, das liegt zum Teil daran, dass man wirklich – in Deutschland spricht man immer gerne von diesem Straßenspieler, der in der Ausbildung ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Leroy Sané als Beispiel nimmt, der ist so die Ausnahme von der Regel ein bisschen. Ich denke aber, gleichzeitig hat man in Deutschland das schon lange verstanden. Man arbeitet jetzt natürlich daran. Das braucht aber gleichzeitig wieder seine Zeit, bis sich das dann auf die Liga auswirkt, etc. Bis dahin müsste man Leute von außen holen. Und diese klassischen Eins-gegen-eins-Spieler, diese Dribbler, die ein bisschen Flair reinbringen in ein Spiel, die sind natürlich teuer, die spielen dann irgendwo anders oder werden möglichst schnell von Spaniern und Portugiesen, die einfach sprachlich näher dran sind, aus Südamerika abgefangen. Da hat die Bundesliga, glaube ich, momentan ein bisschen einen Wettbewerbsnachteil vielleicht. Gleichzeitig wird wahrscheinlich im Hintergrund auch schon dran gearbeitet. In Spanien, da haben wir gerade über die Trainingsarbeit gesprochen, ist das so ein bisschen mehr in den letzten Jahren schon passiert. Das heißt, die profitieren sicherlich auch jetzt davon. Plus eben den Faktor, sie haben die Südamerikaner, sie haben da wirklich eben auch die Spieler, die sie dann abfangen, die sie da groß machen. Plus das gute Scouting-System, das ich ja auch schon kurz angerissen habe. Also so Spieler, die da irgendwo landen, wo man jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt damit rechnet und da wirklich gute Qualitäten haben.
Vielleicht kann ja die Bundesliga mal anfangen und erstmal ein paar der guten Trainer holen und dann können wir mal gucken, ob das was verändert mit dem deutschen Fußball.
Das ist eine interessante Geschichte tatsächlich. Ich habe mich gerade hier auf Las Palmas gedrückt, wo ich gerade die Statistiken angeguckt habe, die die drittmeisten Dribblings haben. Ich habe ja schon gesagt, ich bin so ein bisschen ein Fan von denen, was unter anderem am Trainer liegt. Man muss dazu sagen, sie haben die letzten Spiele nicht gewonnen. Drei verloren, drei unentschieden sind es hier, die letzten sechs. Sie sind vorvorletzter, also momentan auf dem Abstiegsplatz. Aber wir haben mit Paco Jemez wirklich eine sehr mutige Wahl getroffen. Das ist ein Trainer, der sehr, sehr fixiert auf sein Spiel ist. Das, was er sich ausdenkt, möchte er auch auf dem Platz sehen.
Paco Jemez ist quasi spanisch für Roger Schmidt. Von der Fixierung aufs eigene Spielsystem.
Er hat wirklich einen sehr großen Fokus auf gutes Ballbesitzspiel, auf ein schönes Positionsspiel. Das ist wirklich als Mannschaft sehr gut zusammenfunktioniert. Das ist sein absolutes Oberziel. Ich frage mich immer, gibt es denn eine Mannschaft in der Bundesliga, die so eine mutige Entscheidung im Abstiegskampf treffen würde? Wenn ich mir jetzt ansehe, wir haben Labardia bei Wolfsburg, beispielsweise Martin Schmidt hatten wir davor bei Wolfsburg oder bei Mainz, je nachdem, welche Saison man anguckt.
Ich würde Flo Kohfeldt bei Bremen vielleicht in den Ruhm werfen.
Kohfeldt ist genau dieses Ding und jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, wo Bremen in der Tabelle steht und wo Mannschaften wie der HSV oder Wolfsburg sich eben befinden, trotz einer vergleichbaren, wenn nicht sogar besseren Kaderqualität.
Ja, interessante Einblicke waren das aus La Liga. Vielen Dank dir, Ben. Das hat mir großen Spaß gemacht. Das hat mir auch einiges beigebracht über La Liga, muss ich sagen. Das war Ben Barthman von Spox. Vielen Dank dir, dass du Zeit genommen hast. Mal wieder für den Rasenfunk.
Gerne, hat auch mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich sehr. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es gibt diese Woche noch viel zu hören vom Rasenfunk. Es wird unter anderem Ende der Woche noch ein Kurzpass herauskommen. Die aktuelle Schlusskonferenz habt ihr ja vielleicht sogar schon gehört. In der Nacht auf Montag kommt die nächste. Und es sind auch Tribüngespräche in der Mache. Es wird einfach nicht langweilig. Deswegen hören wir uns bald wieder. Macht's gut, bis dahin, ciao!